ん
記念フェンネルの surface の
レンズまっすぐラギアに関する
youtube 動画5人が体験の付に
基づき新たな魅力としいざさんに紹介
いただいた多大なる功績を参照連動最新
商品を受ける深く感謝の余興島平成27年
1月中3立ぺんてる株式会社代表取締役
社長和田勝
4つはダサソー
麻生
ステで今日は月社長からの勝ち提供で本気
でをレンズを紹介しようと思います
今月は遠くたーーーーはじめ大跳びで久し
ぶりの文房具商売で紹介する今回の文房が
こちらをレンズの new color
red 塾ぷるー時グリーン時くそ関税新
施工例角米帝サービスた玉従来の0てみる
と同様の5種類でございますやー
は腸から来るとはまさか
トレード練度しれないけどに説明し
ましょうレンズとは絶対俺ないシャーペン
なことです絶対に
らしく使えばオレンジの一番大きな特徴と
著者ペンにとっては必ずしも出場の
ポジション芯を出さないで書くという
ところでは神様出さずになぜかけるかと
いうとそうオレンズシステムなことがを
レントシステムとは50書くことによって
いるシーンに合わせて選んだパイプ徐々に
スライドするという仕組みではこの
システムを導入したことによって今までに
なかった写真を出さないでかくて新しい
シャーペン時代に突入したのだ馬自身が
出ることがないから芯が折れないそういう
システムでござる芯が出ていない状態が
タイプが常にシーンをサポートしている
状態なので芯が折れることがまずない問題
の鍵こちら別にの5のセンターの1枚紙
滑らかにすることで従来のシャープペン
書道用が夏季号地を実現しているのだまあ
一言で言うと
芯が折れないシャーペンですなぁ0.2よ
ね以前動画で説明したと思うので今回は
こちらの進化なだけ説明していこうと思い
ますこれまでのカラーバリエーションは
ピンクイエローブラックホワイトスカイ
ブルーこの後職だったんですけどもまぁ
なかなか午後智子ポップないるんですよ
あったらいい感じのしかし今回でたネット
グリーンブルーはなかなか濃い色でござい
ます男性しょん心躍らないかねお前たちの
魂たりするバカと中心でこの厚競歩遊びの
カーリングファイターたちを入れ食べない
かねぇ上テレビ以上3カラーが追加された
をレンズ0.2でした
ここからが本番ですよついに次にですねを
レンズの新作レイさんが出ましたはぁっ
うねる
企業タイアップとか関係なくねー純粋に
嬉しいですよねーてサービスを0.3あの
たぶん僕と同じ感覚の人はいると思うん
ですけど0.22のシャーペンって結構
細いんですよ僕そんなに超細い城郭わけで
もないしそんなめちゃくちゃ太い柱を欠く
わけでもないんで0.2よりちょっと太め
の家が書きたかったくらいの感じなんです
よ1ユーザーとしてね言わせていただくと
まぁ走行にうまいことを叶えてくださった
わけですよこの例亭さんで金
ありがたき幸せてれば普通の0.3だと
なんかやっぱ俺やすいっていうイメージが
あるじゃないですか写真を添えてこれ
やすいんだよねデーってさんが出がちな方
で嬉しいです0.2ワイパーちょっと
細かったんですよ好きな人もいると思う
けどねをレンズ0.3の時代さあ
は使ってないけど配球でをレンズを全部
開封してみましたこいつつが0.3でここ
3つが0.2ですかをレンズ何がいいかと
いうとそうシンプルなんですよ肉眼に
にくいと思うんですけどペン先が丸まって
おりますこれが滑らかに描ける秘訣ですね
ちゃんとね芯を出さないで帰ってください
という注意書きもシールで貼ってあります
た事が帰っているとやっぱりちょっとずつ
地金太くなるんですよあと字が汚い
ありがとうございます0.2ですまぁこれ
が普通の状態で
こうです神よ打者ダメですつだけだして
くださいパイプのつだけこれでも描けます
神が出てないように見えるがこれでもかけ
ますからね
書いてみましょうほらすごくねやっぱ
0.2浅瀬がという発作ですよ骨が
0.2mm です次は0.3です a 邸
さんも同様
つっつだけだったけど新を出してはいけ
ませんちょうどいいちょうどいい実に
ちょうどいいちょうどいい子ねやっぱ
0.3が僕的にはベストです問題は写真が
本当に折れないかどうかというところです
折れる気配がこれは本当に折れないと思い
ますはいというわけで一応 day 3
トレイ10人の細さ太さを調べてみたん
ですけどもやっぱりレイプではとっても
細いですね綺麗に描けます米てさんはそれ
の少し一回り太いからいいんですけど
オレンジなんですけど本当に常に細い字が
書けておれませんでねあのペン鳥さんが今
返品キャンペーンをやっているらしくてを
レンズで実際にちゃんと使ってねその
シーンを出せばきっとがたんですよ
ちゃんと使って芯が折れるような事があれ
ば応募用紙にレシートを張って商品と一緒
に事務局に送ると返金というなんと強気な
キャンペーンをやっておりますこれはでも
完全にね俺ないという自信から来てる
キャンペーンだと思いますそれほどの自信
があるペイント予算からの影響でござい
ました是非その受験西店てる絶対俺ない
シャーペンでお前たちの心も
俺んじゃないぞ
ます
しています